no I mean I I frankly do feel that the
the Europeans have a much more mature
overall outlook on you know on this
issue most people in it that I know
anyway who brought up into Europe were
brought up with a little bit of water
blended with wine when they were in
their teens finally with a little bit of
wine at the dinner table you know when
they were in their late teens and by the
time they hit 18 it's not a big deal
anymore and it's really in in countries
that that don't have as mature in
outlook on the issue that tend to have
problems with binge drinking etc I mean
there can be I can see good arguments on
either side but I mean I was responsible
I I went through this weird period where
I was 18 and I was legal and then I
became illegal when they changed the way
when they changed it to 21 and then I
went back to being legal again like you
know two years later I was in this weird
kind of a limbo thing and you know I
think that I was responsible when I was
younger you know you're going to I mean
I don't want to bring up this sort of
all the classic you know well if you can
go and fight in a war and you can't have
a beer all those things it's a
complicated issue but I just do think
that rather than looking at it from a
historical point of view which i think
is often the case that people take a
kamar longview recognizing that that the
enjoyment of alcoholic beverages is a
part of you know human humanity that's
what yeah that's that's part of what we
were we're all about by and large as
human beings I mean we've people believe
that we went from a hunter-gatherer
existence to a settled agricultural
existence in order to have enough grain
to make beer you know it is central to
the human experience and you know it i
think it's a you know and it's healthy
for you I mean in moderation and it's
better for you than not having it
so if you know if you really want to
bring people up properly you know teach
them how to eat properly and teach them
how to drink properly you know I mean if
you want it if you want to ban something
that's going to you know cause a lot of
problems you could say well it's banned
butter you know or let's bend I mean if
you want to look at the overall cost of
the population but better is to teach
people how to cook how to eat and how to
live well oh no they are alcoholics in
Europe I can be quite sure you know I
mean unfortunately I mean alcoholism you
know you know is a disease it is a
problem just as overeating as a disease
I mean beer essentially is food and
people are going to are going to abuse
all sorts of foods you know in different
ways and whether this involves your you
know you know eating this and that and
going to be you know 400 pounds and not
being functional or you know it's an
alcohol problem all these things you
know are going to be problems across the
board in society I think you can take a
more mature outlook on it as a society
and not look at it as weather again it's
you know it's eating or it's alcohol is
it a moral problem or you know is it
really teaching people you know how to
handle themselves you know in a world
that hands everything to you on a
platter and says well here it is for you
to consume and I think that you know um
the Europeans have a better outlook on
it but there are by no means perfect
well I can't say like an answer a
question like that so quickly but I'm
reminded of Francois me Charles last
meal which I thing lasted about two days
you know and had sort of every little
you know you know borderlands and and
whatever else and all of his friends
around him and the greatest the greatest
drinks that you could be broad I mean
I've had I've had beers as old as 1869
which were unbelievable you know III
would be gathering up things for four
years for such an occasion so and like
meet around I would make it that meal
last for like two or three days and say
okay then that's it so it's a not a
question I get a I could I could answer
quickly but I can I can assure you that
it would be awfully good